- Woah, this came from my body.
- When I was younger, I
had so much crazy ear wax
that the doctor had to flood this shit
out of my ear, and it
was like this huge thing
of ear wax.
- I'd say I clean my ears regularly.
- I use Q-tips once in a while.
- I was in a crazy ear wax video recently
where they pulled out
a raisin-sized ear wax,
so now I'm afraid that I'm gonna be known
as the ear wax guy.
- See, this is nice.
It's got a friendly
little Q-tip man on it.
- They look medically sound,
except this guy with a face on it.
- It is so determined to clean my ear.
- Ooo, look at these.
- I'm guessing the sticky
part is the pink side.
- So sticky, just look at this.
- Caution.
Never insert into or
probe past the outer ear.
I think I got this.
- I'll start up here.
If I can just get the outer brim.
- Oh, it feels weird.
- I don't know how hard to press,
because I don't want it
sticking to the walls of my ear.
I'm kind of spinning
it, kind of like how you
would make cotton candy.
- Ah, there we go.
That's the spot.
- I can't even talk right now.
- It's a little firm,
but it almost feels like
a soft foam.
You can see there's
small little gunk in it.
- The sticky think is kinda cool,
because the ones I have
at home are super cottony.
It's just like fluff that
you're putting in your ears,
so I guess it's easier to get it stuck.
- Ooo. It pulls the chunks
out more than just like
smearing it around.
- Oh, my gosh.
You wanna get a closeup of this?
- Time for the white part.
Clean that out.
There we go.
Hmm, that's nasty.
- Ah, let's see if this
makes it un-sticky.
- I don't know if
anything's sticking to it.
Ah.
I feel like that's normal.
It used to be much more than this.
- It doesn't have chunks,
so at least that's good.
It's just stained yellow.
- My ears are clean.
- When I was told that
these were adhesive,
I thought I was going
to have tape in my ears,
and these felt like little
kisses from butterflies.
- I think the stickiness kind
of helps the white part stick
to all of the other things in my ear.
- The pink side pulls out more chunks
than the non-sticky side.
The non-sticky side
just kind of smears it.
- It's definitely super
satisfying to just look at it
and be like, woah, this came from my body.
- I felt like I could
go a little bit further
into my outer ear because I wasn't worried
about cotton getting stuck in it.
It was just amazing.
- This might be worth a
try if you have trouble
with your ears and can't see a doctor yet.
- [Teen Girl] Hmm, that's nasty.